[Musique]
notre premier débat thématique il porte
sur les retraites emmanuel macron a dit
hier qu'il ne faisait pas des 65 ans un
totem qui pourraient consulter les
français par référendum les lignes
bougent mais que propose précisément les
deux candidats réponse avec gaspard
flamand au lendemain du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle c'est une
marche arrière inattendue emmanuel
macron se dit prêt à revenir sur un
point phare de son programme la retraite
à 65 ans il évoque même un référendum
pour adopter cette réforme si il n'y a
pas d'accord la suite je sens sa griffe
peu trop je suis prêt à avoir des
clauses de revoyure qui tôt pour dire
s'ils s'arrêtent avant et les gens
auront à décider et d'envoyer sa savez
je trouve le jeu
si on ne déconne pas l'âge on ne peut
pas financer les pensions minimales sont
supérieurs on ne peut pas réindexés
c'est pas vrai car jusque-là le
président-candidat souhaitait décaler
l'âge de départ à la retraite de quatre
mois par an pour le faire passer de 62 à
65 ans entre 2023 et 2030 aujourd'hui
ils envisageraient de stopper sa réforme
plutôt pour un départ à la retraite
également plus tôt mais sans précision
du côté du rassemblement national marine
le pen s'oppose elle à tout allongement
de l'âge du départ à la retraite elle
s'engage à le maintenir à 62 ans maximum
et même à le baisser à 60 pour les
personnes ayant commencé à travailler
avant 20 ans tous les français vous
savez sont extrêmement intelligents donc
j'ai déjà ils ont tous compris que c'est
une manoeuvre de la part d' emmanuel
macron pour tenter de récupérer ou en
tout cas d'atténuer l'opposition des
électeurs de gauche il n'y a rien à
attendre des manuels macron dans ce
domaine il ira au bout de cette
obsession car en réalité la retraite à
65 ans et son obsession sur les autres
dossiers comme les régimes spéciaux les
deux finalistes sont également opposés
marine le pen souhaite les conserver
emmanuel macron les supprimer à corps en
revanche sur les seuils minimum de
pension ils souhaitent tous les deux les
relevés
et donc on débat autour des retraites
avec une arrivée mais sur le fil de tous
mes invités
bienvenue à tous sans drame hôtes un bon
soir vous êtes député la république en
marche de l'isère hervé fabre aubrespy
bonsoir bienvenue porte parole de marine
le pen stefan liller économistes
bienvenue et bon soir les deux sacres
pas évidemment était resté à mes côtés
c'est fanouillère peut-être on pose un
peu le décor les retraites dans notre
budget dans les dépenses sociales ça
pèse quoi alors c'est la moitié des
dépenses sociales et c'est à peu près 14
% du pub alors c'est
ce chiffre en fait j'ai peut-être pas
parlant mais si on compare par rapport à
ce qui se pratique dans les autres pays
de la zone euro c'est pratiquement le
double donc comme ça pèse énormément et
on sait que tous les ans on fait on
dégage plutôt des déficits publics c'est
à dire qu'il nous manque chaque année de
l'argent dans les caisses de l'état
lorsqu'il faut il faut essayer
d'assainir les comptes c'est normal
qu'on se dise on va regarder là le poste
le plus important quel poste des
retraites il faut trouver des solutions
pour alléger
le poids des dépenses de retraite pour
essayer de
m'améliorer donne la situation de nos
comptes publics comment ça se fait que
nos voisins
dépensent beaucoup moins c'est quoi ces
des systèmes plus tôt privé c'est quoi
alors non c'est surtout que déjà le en
moyenne en fait en europe on part à la
retraite à 65 ans donc nous en fait ces
trois ans supplémentaires parce qu'on
part à 62 l'âge légal donc on paye tous
les ans par rapport aux autres pays on a
un poids supplémentaire de 3 ans donc ça
s'apaise ça pèse énormément et puis on a
aussi tous les régimes spéciaux qui
coûte extrêmement cher en fait il ya une
myriade de petits éléments qui qui font
que et bien en fin de course on est un
pays qui a du mal à s'en sortir au
niveau du système de retraite parce que
aussi on a un système de retraites plus
généreux que les autres pays de la zone
euro et ça rend ce débat évidemment
passionnant est crucial sandra mottin
emmanuel macron votre candidat a déjà
fait évoluer sa proposition phare l'âge
légal reporter progressivement à 65 ans
c'est quoi une reculade non pas du tout
c'est je pense qu'il ya deux choses
importantes la première c'est qu'il faut
entendre les français effectivement et
que canton comme il l'a dit quand on dit
qu'on veut rassembler on entend
effectivement que près de 20 un peu plus
de 20 % des français ont voté pour un
jean luc mélenchon qui promettait lui
une retraite à 60 ans et donc on entend
effectivement la crainte des français
est d'ailleurs mais callière moi je le
fais tous les ans une enquête du cercle
des économistes qui regardent
particulièrement les questions de
retraite pour voir que les français
veulent encore majoritairement partir à
60 ans alors même que l'âge de départ à
la retraite aujourd'hui en moyenne il
est à 62
[Musique]
65 ans alors l'idée ensuite c'est de se
dire que de toute façon une telle
réforme on ne l'a même pas seuls on ne
peut l'amener qu'avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales
on peut les mener on peut mener ce type
de réforme et on en a fait les frais on
a bien vu on a essayé lors du mandat qui
s'achève de réformer finalement alors
après quand même beaucoup de discussions
jean paul delevoye avait mené en cycle
de discussions très long mais qui
pourtant n'avait pas suffi pour un
système universel qui était très très
complexe là on va sur quelque chose de
moins complexe mais de très impactant et
donc concrètement il faut qu'on ait se
rendre de négociations on peut pas
rentrer en négociations en disant voilà
mais il rouge et s'associe avec le
peuple parce que si on fait un
référendum ça va même au delà de la
négociation avec les partenaires sociaux
en pour le coup je vous dirais un
référendum je ne sais pas à un moment
quand on parle aux corps intermédiaires
normalement ils sont censés aussi être
présentée si la fao a repoussé l'idée
d'un référentiel macro on y reviendra
sur sur la méthode hervé fabre aubrespy
votre candidate elle ne touche pas
o 62 ans c'est ça un peu le principe
général je suis j'aimerais faire
remarquer d'abord et aussi référendum il
ya c'est oui ou non vous pouvez pas
évidemment modifier le texte et par
ailleurs je m'adresse à la députée la
république en marche qui est là et les
réformes ont été effectivement lancée et
là est ce que le volte-face du candidat
emmanuel macron est autre chose que
purement électoralistes l'escale est
fait quelle est sa motivation
vous dit écoutez le peuple mais c'est
écouter qui les électeurs leur temps de
la mare changé c'est écouter l'ensemble
des français est de toute façon je vais
vous dire il n'y a pas de surprise si
malaise sur les 60 sont énormes à
l'écouté avant ils n'ont jusque là
question en fait c'est celle de la
méthode la méthode que le président
propose justement pour ce nouveau
quinquennat et pour tous les sujets il
l'a dit pour l'éducation il l'a dit pour
la santé c'est celle effectivement de
mettre autour de la table des parties
prenantes quand on prend des décisions
aussi structurantes et aussi impactante
pour les français dans notre pays on
doit le faire en concertation n'a jamais
dit autre chose y compris sur les
retraites il a toujours dit d'ailleurs
être dès le premier tour que ce ne
serait pas dans les sons jours qu'il n'y
avait pas forcément d'urgence et qu'il
fallait qu'ils aient ce temps de
dialogue important il entend les
français et il dit simplement que là il
n'y a pas de ligne rouge le 8 mars il
s'est prononcé il a déclaré ce sera 65
ans celui de parce ça n'a pas changé de
discours mais ça fait part à des
incivilités aujourd'hui en action
présidentielle de dimanche dernier mais
ça fait ensuite du parti il chanta fait
encore partie les possibilités la
question elle et se dire est ce que
c'est une ligne rouge ou pas il y a
répondu il ya ou non ce n'est pas une
ligne rouge puisque
est-ce que marine le pen
entendra participera à des fins fera en
sorte qu'ils aient des négociations quel
rôle les partenaires sociaux auront dans
sa réforme il ya des rôles qui sont de
toute façon prévue par la législation
quand on fait une moyenne donc elle ne
sapera pas le rôle des partenaires sont
bien entendu que que non mais à
l'annonce très clairement ce qu'elle
veut faire et ce qu'elle veut faire
c'est quoi c'est une réforme qui est une
réforme qui s'adresse à tous les
français quittent une réforme juste elle
consiste tout de même à tenir compte de
l'âge auquel on a commencé à travailler
de tenir compte donc de la pénibilité du
travail parce qu'en général les travaux
que l'on fait à partir de 17 h ou 20 ans
sont évidemment plus dur l'espérance de
vie est moins forte moins grande moins
élevé pour les ouvriers que pour les
classes plus suis supérieur et donc elle
propose effectivement que si on a
commencé à travailler avant 20 ans et
bien après quarante annuités et on part
à l'âge de retraite à 60 ans et puis
ensuite un étalement pour arriver à
l'âge actuel si on a fait des études
plutôt long on partira à quel âge 64 65
66 pas me dire ah non on partira avec
eux les
quatre ans à 66 ans j'ai fait quelques
unes avec vos quarante deux années des
nuitées ça nous fait du 66 ans un nom
tout sortira à l'aja l'âge voulu
tout à l'heure actuelle mais c'est vrai
qu'à 40 seulement si vous avez commencé
à 20 ans donc ce qui va coûter quelque
temps un peu d'argent mais après j'ai
bien lu le programme de votre candidate
finalement on ajoute quelque part
quelques trimestres par an si
progressive jusqu'à 100 ce qui fait que
à l'âge alain jouen jeunes aujourd'hui
rentrer en moyenne sur le marché du
travail c'est-à-dire en gros avec un peu
plus de 21 ans moi j'ai pris le 1 en 21
ans et demi effectivement dans votre
système à 62 ans donc comme aujourd'hui
rien ne change pour lui par contre pour
ceux qui vont faire des études et vous
savez quand même quand on a la chance en
france d'avoir un système éducatif qui
est performant et qui amène plus en plus
de jeunes à faire des études longues
qu'est ce qui leur arrive a eu à 24 ans
6 et s'ils rentrent à 24 ans sur le
marché du travail ses 66 ans
voilà c'est ça aujourd'hui votre énorme
d'abord d'abord l'insécurité 42 ans vous
le savez ça va coûter très cher vous
pourrez nous le confirme et nous avons
un taux d'activité des jeunes moins
élevé que dans le reste des pays
européens oui parce qu'ils font
justement ils font les études dont la
problématique de 12 aces et surtout que
auront les cotisants sont pas assez
nombreux pour payer lés retraités oui
qu'en moyenne dans l'incitation au
travail pour les jeunes d'où les mesures
qui sont prises pour inciter à lancer le
travail pour les jeunes vont pas payer
non plus d'impôt sur le revenu alors en
fait ça fait quand même beaucoup
en face à saïda quoi parce que les
cotisations retraite parce que je suis
obligé de d'expliquer les corrélations
cia 1,4 actifs aujourd'hui qu'ils payent
pour un retraité on se doute bien que
1,4 actifs ne peut pas prendre en charge
le montant que représente une pension de
retraite donc que fait l'état il obligé
de puiser dans ses caisses et notamment
à travers l'impôt et comme en fait il
est déficitaire qu'est ce qu'il fait il
s'endette donc envie de ça va être ça le
problème est donc des deux systèmes
aussi en fait c'est déjà ça notre notre
problème c'est qu'on est obligé de
s'endetter pour financer les retraites
de l'air est ce que sans mesures d'âge
on peut s'en sortir on pouvait faire il
y avait des réformes en fait sur ben en
fait on est moins
un des phares - des misères les pensions
de retraite peuvent diminuer par exemple
en disant les cotisants peut pas leur
demander plus ou alors on fait quoi si
c'est un salarié ou alors les
entreprises ciel
voilà on sait que ba aujourd'hui il ya
une overdose fiscales et sociales de
charges sociales qui fait que c'est
difficile de dire aux actifs vous allez
alors cela aussi je lis musulin nombre
de pensionnés regardez plus exactement
si tous les pensionnés s'il n'y a pas de
fraude sont dans l'erreur je fais là
dans les rapports sur la fraude sociale
que l'on a pu voir ici enfin au sénat et
ailleurs il y à une interrogation sur la
réalité de toutes les pensions de
retraite et un rapport de la cour des
comptes qui montrait clairement par
exemple pas il ya 7 milliards environ de
pension qui ne sont pas versés à des
gens qui en droit notamment dans les
caisses complémentaires des salariés du
privé dont vous voyez on peut aussi
prendre le problème à non mais alors je
vais vous donner la parole à tous les
deux évidemment mais on va faire un peu
de l'analyse peut-être d'abord la liste
de
de communication politique avait avec
vous laetitia sur ce totem qui était le
totem du premier tour la retraite à 65
ans et est ce changement de pied on
pourrait dire ça comme ça oui alors
politiquement on comprend exactement la
stratégie d' emmanuel marc macron c'est
à dire qu'au premier tour il donne à
marqueur de droite donc il tend la main
à droite avec cet âge qu'il lui même
qu'il met tout de suite adobe d'entrer
dans sa campagne 65 ans pour la retraite
et ensuite il a bien compris que c'était
à gauche que ça allait se passer pour
lui en tout cas la qualification finale
et donc il tend la main à gauche et il
nuance parce que ce n'est pas une volte
face total mais il nuance
c'est l'histoire si vous voulez qu'il
est en train de nous raconte emmanuel
macron parce qu'il ya toujours une
histoire derrière tout cela c'est vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs très très bien je
suis allé sur le terrain à la rencontre
hier dans le nord des français qui n'ont
pas voté pour moi et je les ai entendus
et après cette déambulation cette
confrontation je me suis dit face à
bruce toussaint sur bfm tv et bien non
finalement je vais peut-être pas faire
65 peut-être 64 en tout cas je suis
ouvert à la discussion ça peut marcher
ça peut marcher pourquoi parce que la
symbolique c'est l'ouverture l'écoutent
la capacité à prendre en compte la
contestation et a changé mais le cologne
samedi le symbolique c'est quand même le
renoncement c'est aussi le manque de
courage politique ne pas aller au bout
de ce que l'on a annoncé en entrant en
campagne et ça ça peut compter des
points dans la course bien sûr électoral
et surtout thomas en opérant de la sorte
il ya une question que je me suis posée
il donc je pense que beaucoup se posent
emmanuel macron met le projecteur
médiatique sur cette question des
retraites cela fait deux jours que l'on
en parle et à mon avis ça après 1
c'était vraiment comme un sujet fort de
cette campagne de deuxième tour or ces
avantages me semble-t-il sont plus sur
l'europe par exemple sur le bilan de sa
politique sanitaire pendant le coc vide
il a un bilan positif emmanuel macron et
la protéger les français de la pandémie
il y à d'autres sujets le plein emploi
est donc volontairement il et placer le
curseur sur ce sujet peut-être que c'est
un risque qu'il a pris on le verra bien
sûr dans quinze jours peut-être pas
sandra motta est ce que la porte est
ouverte en quelque sorte où la main
tendue sur beaucoup de thématiques alors
moi j'ai voulu dire pour prendre une
petite formule rigolote la porte elle
est pas ouverte à toutes les fenêtres
concrètement il ya une chose qui est
importante oui 65 ans ça peut être un
marqueur mais ce qui est important est
là où finalement emmanuel macron gardes
le fouillent vraiment le fondamental de
la réforme des retraites c'est d'abord
qu'on recherche un équilibre on cherche
un équilibre du système
on va le faire par le travail parce que
là dessus on lâche rien oui va falloir
travailler plus c'est important mais du
coup il va falloir aussi protéger mieux
protégés mieux ceux qui ont des
carrières difficile et faire en sorte
aussi que finalement les fruits de ce
travail mais ils soient redistribuées
avec une pension qui peut au besoin qui
augmentera à nice en euros donc tout ça
c'est important aussi et donc là dessus
s'est même amusé qu'on a plein milieu
des manèges et on ne lâche rien et
effectivement surtout en garde deux
autres fondamentaux qu'on a toujours eu
on n'augmente pas les cotisations des
entreprises on vient de faire 25
milliards de baisses de charges pour les
entreprises fiscales notamment on
s'apprête à en refaire encore sur
d'autres impôts de production pour 7
milliards donc il est hors de question
d'augmenter des cotisations il est hors
de question de baisser les pensions au
contraire on veut augmenter les quitte
donc en fait on ne change pas nous
livrons d'hawaï et mieux toute la
complexité des ces sympathiques mais
d'avancé 65 ans et pour moi c'est un
chiffre et leur emmanuel macron dit ce
n'est pas un chiffre magique mais c'est
quand même lui qui l'a mis dans le débat
public et le problème c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a un prix mais l'opinion publique
et que ce chiffre un peu totem vous avez
raison thomas après il faut femme est
blessée et de pédagogie mais marie jo
chen hong avait une divergence de chez
véro que je t'aime pas reçus moi c'est
sur les marchés marine le pen jouer les
marges elles étaient parties à 60 ans
voilà deux semaines
les gens en parlent encore parce qu'elle
n'est pas suffisamment clair
oui elle a fait avant le premier tour
elle le fait pas et à la vision du
mordant mais sur laquelle me disait pas
la même chose et qu'ils ont entretenu le
fou
vous dire quand même parce que ça vous
est particulièrement bien placé il ya eu
quand même une tentative de réforme
pendant le match agen était rapporteur
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait exactement parce
que à ma connaissance le projet de loi
organique dont vous avez été là rapport
à leur projet ordinaire il n'a pas été
retirée non elles n'ont pas été retirés
mais comme beaucoup pour moi voulait
retirer pas parce qu'au jury à face
concrètement on en a eu une des crises à
gérer c'est d'ailleurs même pour être
tiré à terre c'est très facile le
gouvernement peut retirer à tout moment
ce texte a été adopté à l'assemblée
nationale après les événements que l'on
sait aujourd'hui
technip il est garanti puisque vous
évoluer puisque si jamais monsieur
mais une élection présidentielle c'est
quand même le bon moment pour poser aux
français la question qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que qu'on fasse deux de vos
retraites et la question du financement
comment donc comment vous combler le
déficit des systèmes de retraite rituel
sans travailler plus longtemps parce que
9 milliards des projets écoutez nord il
a été chiffré il a chiffré les économies
sur la fraude 18 milliards sur
l'immigration parce que c'est quand même
un sujet ça elle nous allons réformer la
politique conduite depuis maintenant
1980 pratiquement qui est la porte
ouverte à tous les immigrés la
générosité qui fait que des allocations
sont versées à tort et à travers des
fraudes qui sont signalés et que comme
comme comme je les dis et donc il y aura
largement de quoi financer les nouvelles
mesures en ce qui concerne les retraites
qui sont chiffrées à peu près à 8
milliards et aussi un programme chiffré
équilibré qui a été présentée par marine
le pen a récemment et qui est un projet
sérieux vu par des personnes qui ont
regardé les différentes
composante et j'ajoute effectivement que
parce que ça aussi ça a été de nouveau
comme annonce de la part du candidat
emmanuel macron c'est que il y à des
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités c'est la pension de retraite
c'est une des thématiques la parole là
dessus sur le mail à la revalorisation
des pensions
quelqu'un qui m'a dit j'ai perdu 300
euros par mois depuis deux ans
une retraitée elle m'a dit j'ai perdu
300 euros par mois et elle m'a montré
bien son nom mais bien de son moi c'est
d'abord je vous transmettrai ci-après
dessous je pense qu'une trêve hivernale
avant sur le bien que vous avez étudié
ce que proposait
ce qui est assez curieux c'est en fait
c'est les chiffres qui sont donnés c'est
à dire faire croire que et bien le poids
d aide aux immigrés va pouvoir
réellement laissé une bouffée d'oxygène
pour financer une myriade dead parce
qu'il n'ya pas uniquement les retraites
il ya toutes les aides comme les
revisiter la lauze et combien vous avez
carte vitale en circulation combien d or
en fait cela c'est du domaine de 2 de
l'économie en fait c est ce que ça
suffit
il suffit d y adhérer réalité comptable
en fait on peut pas effacer ça on sait
que quinze dealers de nom en faire si
vous regardez
c'est ce que vous annoncez une fraude
fiscale si elle pouvait être annoncées
de manière objective du
régime social c'est justement la fraude
fait que c'est très compliqué à évaluer
la capacité de cette de cette économie
souterraine
je veux pas revenir mais pas entre la
grèce mardi mais non mais la grèce qui s
et des estimations la grèce qui a fait
partie de l'europe parce qu'on
considérait que la journée de vingt ans
auparavant dix ans on n'a qu'à
considérer l'économie souterraine de la
grèce parce que lorsqu'elle va venir
dans la zone euro cette économie
souterraine va devenir visibles on a vu
ce que ça a donné donc une économie
souterraine en fait c'est justement
échapper à l'impôt donc c'est plus
compliqué déjà de l'estimé et de et 2 et
de récupérer et surtout misé sa
politique et ses économies que sur ce
facteur là je pense qu'on ne peut pas
l'en de réponse de l'europe en disant on
va financer notre programme sur la
fraude fiscale et sociale et voulez vous
convaincre l'europe
comment l'europe alors là vous savez
j'ai été député européen entre 1994 et
1999 j'étais pour une autre europe et
tous ceux qui étaient pour l'europe ne
sais c'est comme le disait marie france
garaud que de faire des incantations il
n'était pas du tout européen
cinq ans
destiné à convaincre l'europe j'imagine
que non mais mais mais l'europe sera
convaincu parce que nous avons beaucoup
de d'autres pays qui veulent modifier on
disait à l'époque
changer l'europe être contre l'europe et
on est qualifiés d'extrême droite ce que
je n'ai jamais été puisque j'étais dans
un groupe europe des nations et donc on
n'a jamais voulu modifier les choses en
europe il y aura une volonté
si marine le pen est élue il y aura
d'autres pays qui tiendront compte de la
du du vote des français et il y aura un
changement au niveau européen et sur le
chemin à notre débat demain sur l'europe
donc allez-y sur le chiffrage sur le
chiffrage il est allé 15 milliards
d'euros que j'ai annoncée comme étant
récupérée sur tout ce qui est
l'immigration et il a 18 milliards sur
la fraude et encore une fois ce sont des
chiffres qui sont dans des rapports qui
ont été évalués je n'allais pas à un
mode raymond ça tu sens la montagne puis
ensuite on va on va passer au crible
quand même l'une des alors c'est pas
tout à fait une proposition a été
évoquée par la cour la possibilité de
passer par un référendum on y viendra
dans un instant avec steve jours d'un
mode réponse là dessus moi je suis
toujours impressionné par effectivement
ces chiffres qu'on lance comme ça sur la
fraude qu'elles soient sociales ou
fiscales
mais par contre je vois jamais les
propositions concrètes pour lutter
contre cette fraude et je vais vous dire
moi on en a fait deux nous des choses
très concrètes pour pour lutter contre
la fraude d'abord on a mis la
déclaration sociale nominative en place
c'est quelque chose qui oblige tous les
employeurs a déclaré un parent toutes
les charges qui payent pour leurs
salariés ça réduit la fraude sociale
dans les entreprises et c'était là l'un
des principaux postes il comprit travail
nadjari ce qu'on a fait c'est sur le
prélèvement à la source là encore on a
réduit drastiquement la fraude est ce
que nous proposons pour réduire
réellement la fraude sociale monsieur
c'est les allocations à la source c'est
faire en sorte que les gens n'aient plus
besoin de demander et qu'on leur
attribue directement leurs droits non
seulement on passera des droits
théoriques ou droits réels mais en plus
de ça on évitera effectivement que des
gens fassent pas ce que ça a été le cas
des fois dix ou quinze dossiers dans dix
ou quinze départements différents pour
toucher des allocations le rappeler le
problème là puisque pendant ces
événements leur droit mais on a lutté
contre ça monsieur notamment en ce
moment même temps en mettant les caf en
réseau par exemple en informatique et
oui ça fait partie des solutions
concrètes de gratteux réel non concrètes
et riaient qui existe le problème c'est
que vous n'avez vous que des
incantations comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure pas du team encore entendus
alors dites-moi créé les la wilaya par
exemple le maire de perpignan quelqu'un
trouver la situation dans sa mairie à
lille la redresse à l avenir on c'est la
même chose non mais j'ai
toujours lutté contre la fraude sociale
pour rendre un phénomène de l'ordre
social d'abord il à la recherche de
toutes les personnes qui sont en
situation de clandestinité
alors il ya
la carte vitale la carte vitale qui
pourra être réformé pour éviter les
allers déjà la folie c'est déjà
difficile aujourd'hui oui enfin c'est
beau le plus difficile mais enfin on
estime que même qu'il ya plusieurs
millions ont été âpres et vital en
circulation qui ne correspondent pas
d'arrêt en fait alors c'était vital pas
l'utilisation qui en est faite c'était
lié à l époque l'un des dames en fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas leur propre numéro
de sécurité sociale et qui était ce que
celui de leur mari ou à l'arrivée c'est
qu'ils vont tout début et donc on a vous
en tout cas les chiffres de caser dans
la rue milliards que j'ai cités sont
alors dieu et ses positions en crète
pour lui le débat n'est pas fini il
reste du temps est vrai qu'on se
concentre maintenant grâce à steve
jourdain sur cette question de
l'utilisation d'un référendum steve doit
être par l'argon soir sylvain deroeux
bienvenus donc il ya effectivement ce
que emmanuel macron a évoqué il a dit
qu'il pourrait soumettre cette
proposition retraite à 65 ou 64 ans à
référendum est ce que c'est légal là on
va l'écouter déjà et puis j'ai serré de
vous répondre ensuite testé hier sur bfm
tv écouter emmanuel macron
parce que sur cette question si sensible
un référendum
peut être envisagée je ne sais pas votre
nom j'explose offic je ne l'exclus pas
le référendum pour quelques réformes que
ce soit je ne l'exclus pas alors est-ce
qu'un référendum sur cette question
c'est légal oui ça l'est comment ce
référendum pourrait être organisé il ya
deux moyens qui sont prévues par la
constitution pour organiser un
référendum ni l article 11 ou l'article
89 l'article 11 il prévoit une
consultation des français sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics ou
encore sur les sujets économiques et
sociaux l'article 89 lui porte sur la
révision de la constitution clairement
dans le cadre de cette éventuelle
réforme des retraites on est dans le
cadre de l'article 11 c'est en tout cas
l'avis de vincent couronne docteur en
droit public
on écoute
vandomme surtout en passant par
l'article 11 par exemple on peut faire
un référendum pour
un projet de loi relatif à
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics ou
alors projets de loi en matière
environnementale sociale et économique
sur la question des services publics ou
dernière possibilité pour la
ratification d'un traité international
il peut tout à fait faire un référendum
de l'article 11
sur la question des retraites puisque la
question des retraites une question
sociale
quelle pourrait être la question posée
aux français quand c'est là toute la
question avant d'y répondre peut être un
mot de procédure le chef de l'état
soumet donc un projet de loi aux
français si ce texte est adopté et bien
il ensuite promulguée par le président
de la république pas besoin de repasser
par le parlement a besoin d'être re
discuté par les élus heures quelle
question pourrait donc être posée par le
chef de l'état aux français en matière
de retraite on a posé la question à
vincent couronne
la question ça serait approuvez vous le
projet de loi
que je vous soumets et donc sur le
bulletin il y aurait donc dans la
question il y aurait donc ce projet de
loi qui serait probablement formulées
sous forme de un deux ou trois articles
pour pas que ce soit trop long
et donc ces quelques articles là où il
peut y en avoir plus détaillerait la
réforme des retraites en tout cas un tel
référendum sur un tel sujet sur serait
complètement inédite depuis la création
la vème république il ya eu neuf
référendum au total huit d'entre eux
sont passés par la voix de l'article 11
on allait voir à l'écran on a demandé
aux français ce qu'ils pensaient de
l'algérie française ce qu'il pensait de
plus d'union européenne et même ce qu'il
pensait du sénat c'était le général de
gaulle à l'époque mais jamais jamais
aucun référendum n'a porté sur une
question économique et sociale aussi
spécifique que celle des retraites merci
steve jourdain pour pour cet éclairage
100 g au/t c'est le pardon c'est un peu
triviale mais c'est un peu casse gueule
quand même un référendum sur sur une
réforme des retraites parce que on l'a
dit c'est binaire c'est oui ou non alors
même si derrière il ya le projet de loi
elles répondent par oui ou non à une
réforme aussi complexe alors je pense
que si référendum il y avait ce serait
sur des mesures précises les plus
compréhensible possible c'est sûr que
sur un si on commence à rentrer dans la
technique vraiment les français ne s'y
retrouveront pas ne pourront pas
réellement se positionner après je crois
que s'il ya une si on a une vraie
concertation très longue avec beaucoup
de parties prenantes autour de la table
des syndicats des français vraiment
enfin des gens un peu en mode on va dire
convention citoyenne grand débat
national sur le sujet
et que finalement on se rend compte que
les français ont vraiment réussi à
s'emparer des tenants et des
aboutissants du sujet pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas mais vraiment effectivement
ce serait tout à fait inédit et quelque
part un peu risqué non pas sur le fond
mais sur sur le fait que les français je
crois en garder en mémoire le dernier
référendum comme marque assez indélébile
de d'une trahison du politique par
rapport à ce qui s'était exprimée 5 pour
la constitution européenne csah et du
coup est-ce que mettre sur la table un
sujet comme celui là aussi sensible
serait une bonne idée je crois que pour
ça ça nécessiterait vraiment un temps de
préparation et de discussions très long
mais fabre aubrespy marine le pen tenait
une conférence de presse cet après midi
sur son droit national de l a beaucoup
parlé on va faire donc c'est vraiment
sous différentes formes d'ailleurs il ya
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne ya
le référendum pour réformer la
constitution est ce que dans le cadre
d'une réforme comme celle dont on parle
c'est le thème de notre débat les
retraites elle pourrait utiliser le
référendum est ce que ça vous semble
être la bonne méthode ça ne sera pas
forcément nécessaire puisqu'elle a
annoncé très clairement ce qu'elle
ferait et donc elle son élection lui
permettrait d'engager la procédure
législative normal pour adopter ce texte
il était fait remarquer que l'article 11
n'a pas sur la politique économique et
sociale et environnementale et est très
souvent utilisé dans la réforme existent
depuis 95 ensuite modifié en 2005 je
crois ou 2003 et est donc
j'observe que le président emmanuel
macron n'a jamais utilisé le référendum
pendant cinq ans alors qu'il aurait pu
le faire il aurait pu le faire sur
l'article 11 il ya eu deux cas avant le
référendum de 2005 il ya eu à référendum
je suis désolé de revenir à des années
lointaines mais enfin 1992 c'est pas si
loin le traité de maastricht je peux
vous dire c'était 80 pages qui ont été
proposées à l'assentiment des français
ils ont bien compris ce dont il s'agit
c'est donc le marine le pen a proposé
effectivement le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne 500 mille citoyens qui
pourront le proposer dans certaines
conditions l'extension aussi du champ
d'application du référendum et le
contrôle de sorman d'année
une loi qui aurait été votée par les
parlementaires non non non pour noms
proposés pour la modifier par la suite
une loi pour modifier
attendez vous n'avez pas de quoi vous
l'avez pas d'hésitation chez son ami
compris de sa conférence
est là bien au contraire elle a interdit
que l'on puisse faire ce qui a été fait
entre 2005 et 2008 c'est à dire de
revenir sur un vote négatif de la
population
comme le peuple pourra changer un texte
qui a été voté par les élus du ce mais
papa pas une loi en vigueur il pourra
être proposé de modifier cette loi mais
ça sera évidemment pas immédiatement il
est prévu il est prévu que ben elle le
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
il n'y a pas d'engagement du président
de la république de la présidente sim a
rien de fait on n'a rien qu'à mais
attendez attendez nous l'expliqué comme
ça toi mais non mais référendum
d'initiative citoyenne vous vous avez
peur du peuple ah non votre président il
a peur de la population
point qui va
d'ailleurs il en veut de la sélectionner
mais
il ne faut pas avoir peur du suffrage
universel
la souveraineté nationale sur elle
appartient au peuple français qui
l'exercent par la voix de ses
représentants ou par la voie du
référendum donc le référendum est
effectivement une bonne façon de faire
trancher des questions aux citoyens à ce
que propose marine le pen c'est quelque
chose qui n'a pas été mis en place par
nicolas sarkozy à l'époque c'est-à-dire
à référendum d'initiative citoyenne
il reste cinq cent mille cinq cent mille
citoyens qui seront avec des conditions
de répartition pour représenter bien la
population et qui propose un référendum
dans cette proposition sera soumise à
référendum s'il remplit les conditions
mais le président la république la
présidente ou le gouvernement ne sont
pas engagés dont ne veulent pas enlever
leurs responsabilités en relation
toutes les lois ce qu'on n'aura pas le
droit de faire
c'est si un référendum à trancher une
question de la sphère tranché en sens
différent par le parlement avant une
durée de 15 ans
et pas dans l'autre bien d'accord mais
c'est ce qu'on a compris alors j'en
viens au thème des retraites possède
pour parler des régimes spéciaux parce
que c'est quelque chose d'important
stephenie meyer il y en a combien ça
touche combien de français des régimes
spéciaux aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
une veille allen c'est oui j'irai car en
union et une quarantaine
oui et puis on fait une certaine forme
d'injustice de traitement par rapport à
la retraite
comment est d'ailleurs il ya un problème
d' injustice global parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que le système est pas
efficients sa part contre la réforme est
nécessaire c'est à dire que on peut
travailler le même 40 ans avec le même
salaire et bien au final on part avec
une retraite qui est différente il ya
vraiment des choses à rééquilibrer à
renégocier pour autant moi je dirais
quand même que le couac il en coûtera
réellement brouillé l'objectivité des
citoyen et c'est un immense problème
parce que effectivement aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'on va avoir le choix est
ce qu'on veut partir à 60 ans ou à 64
ans ou 65 ans comme s'il n'y avait pas
de contraintes financières or nous en
fait derrière jeu là je le redis c'est
pour ça que je parlais de l'europe
l'europe la bce a bien voulu financer la
totalité de cette période crise qu vide
mais elle va pas financer un système de
retraite totalement déséquilibrée parce
que je voulais dit en préambule
en moyenne en europe ont pas à la
retraite à 65 ans alors pourquoi
aujourd'hui l'europe devrait financer un
système le système français trop
généreux ou plus généreux qu'ailleurs et
donc c'est véritablement cette
problématique oumé mais c'est
véritablement un problème du quinquennat
précédent c'est qu'on n'a pas expliqué
en fait que cette situation était
totalement transit temporaire qu'elle
était en accord avec les 19 pays membres
et il n'était pas question de d'utiliser
l'argent magique de manière infinie
c'est une drogue dure
c'est la partie
viens au régime aux régimes spéciaux
parce que sandra motta emmanuel macron a
dit que je cite un ces régimes spéciaux
ne conviennent plus à la réalité du pays
alors qu'est ce qui est prévu il valait
supprimer certains tous à quel rythme on
a déjà on en a déjà on en a déjà
supprimés a en fait celui de la sncf
en faisant en sorte que les nouveaux
entrants
soit dans un système différent
l'idée c'est d'une part de ne pas rompre
le contrat social avec des gens qui sont
rentrés dans un système dont les
salaires d'ailleurs des fois on des
courbes de progression qui sont
complètement lié à ce système de
retraite parce que quand on calcule
votre retraite sur les six derniers mois
de votre carrière c'est pas la même
chose que quand on la calcule sur les 25
années donc ils vont être pas très bien
payé pendant longtemps et on l'est on
les fait mieux
revenu au début et puis tout d'un coup
ça augmente et donc tout ça il faut
qu'on prenne en compte donc du coup
l'idée c'est plutôt de se dire voilà on
va faire en sorte que les nouveaux
entrants est un nouveau contrat social
avec des revalorisations du coût des
salaires c'est ce qu'on a commencé avec
à faire avec les profs par exemple pour
faire en sorte que les carrières soit
beaucoup mieux payé au début et donc on
est cette progressivité donc sa demande
vraiment à chaque fois qu'on veut
s'attaquer à ce type d'injustice de
rectifier et de corriger aussi un
certain nombre de paramètres dans la
carrière de manière à analyser personne
parce qu'il n'est pas question non plus
de dire à quelqu'un qui est par exemple
en milieu de carrière dans un régime je
pense par exemple aux industries
gazières et électriques
aujourd'hui de lui dire bah voila tu es
à la lutte et à la moitié de sa carrière
tu as eu donc un salaire qui n'était pas
génial pendant toute cette première
partie de carrière ça va augmenter après
mais on va quand même de calculer tard
13 sur 25 ans que je souffrais ont tous
d'arabes pour les nouveaux entrants sur
voilà d'accord on appelle la cause du
grand baie ok la clause du grand père
que propose marine le pen en la matière
est-ce qu'elle supprime les les régimes
spéciaux n'ont pas elle les garde
dans les régimes spéciaux ils sont pas
tous déficitaires alors oui je ferai
remarquer oui oui ma faim l'honnêteté ça
serait quand même de le dire par
ailleurs le nez de thé conduit aussi
quand on est dans un débat électoral
comme celui l'élection présidentielle
annoncée ce qu'on va faire quels régimes
spéciaux seront concernés par ce que
vous devez bien ce qui coûte de l'argent
en france est aujourd'hui par exemple on
n'ira pas et le président l'a dit
d'ailleurs de manière très claire on
n'ira pas sur les caisses de retraite
autonome des professions libérales par
exemple j'ai entendu fait clair dans la
bougie cf
ça fait partie effectivement des régimes
qui pèse lourd aujourd'hui dans nos
comptes est par exemple pour être très
clair aussi des régimes et micro régime
tels que ceux de l'opéra de paris ou de
la comédie française pense pas qu'on
ciré attaquera aujourd'hui jeudi le
journaliste voilà non les journalistes
de retraite moi il n'y a pas de jeunes
sans
cesse que dans votre système vous
revoyez les critères de pénibilité des
métiers pénibles d'aujourd'hui sont pas
forcément ceux d un
dispositif des carrières longues
c'est tout sauf quelque chose qui a
marché une usine à gaz ce qu'il faut
c'est considérer l'âge à partir duquel
on travaille ne pas faire de distinction
sur la pénibilité est appliqué ce que
marine le pen a proposé avec un départ
plus rapide pour les personnes qui ont
travaillé plus tôt alors donc je vais
que j'ai vu il n'ya pas très longtemps
aux nuits de donc aux nuits des diplômés
de l'école d'apprentis qui est à
bourgoin jallieu à côté de chez moi donc
le f et mac est une superbe école donc
je vais dire à la jeune fille qui s'est
présenté donc il y avait trop petit
trentaine d'années qui a fait un bac +4
en infographie n'a pas réussi à trouver
de travail qui donc s'est reconverti
dans la coiffure d'accord où elle va
rester deux boutons temps où elle va
être en contact avec des produits
chimiques toute la journée avec les
couleurs qu'en fait dans nos cheveux qui
est un métier difficile qui provoque des
fois des arthroses au niveau des mains
est là comment elle va commencer elle
vraiment sa carrière après mauvaise
orientation je vais lui dire de toute
façon tu vas faire quarante deux ans au
point barre et donc tu vas sortir à 70
ans jean sans jamais prendre en compte
que la maniabilité dans son métier
qu'est ce que vous lui dites aujourd'hui
et bien aujourd'hui on lui aujourd'hui
avec le système actuel avec le système
actuel elle a des horaires qui sont
décalées donc du coup elle a des points
effectivement sur la pénibilité on vient
dans la salle un protégé de pascal a
commencé plus tard oui mais aujourd'hui
en tant qu on peut importe qu'elle ait
commencé tard ou pas dès qu'un métier
est difficile on prend en compte et
notre objectif à nous c'est justement
d'individualiser ces parcours de façon à
faire en sorte que oui des gens qui ont
eu à des moments des métiers qui avait
divers facteurs de pénibilité bas on
puisse effectivement tout au long de
leur carrière les protégés parce que ces
salons de ce débat merci à tous d'y
avoir participé